there are stories about what happened
strong
all of it
hi I'm Mike semi-firm FX guide.com for
Wired the force awakens has been
nominated for an Academy Award for
visual effects and it's easy to see why
the team and ILM headed by Roger guy
have done amazing work in a vast range
of areas from stunning action sequences
both in space and on the ground robots
of course as well as environment work
and set extensions and much much more
director JJ Abrams brought back a host
of old friends but thanks to ILM we also
have a bunch of new characters Islands
character work is exceptional and while
Neal Scanlan special effects group
provided an amazing set of in-camera
prosthetics and special effects makeup
obviously some of the characters
couldn't just be done physically and in
those occasions JJ was more than happy
to push the digital technology of fully
digital actors but of course based on
the performance of real actors such as
Lupita Nyong'o who plays Mars this
process starts with character design and
a full marquette which was made and
scanned from this her muscles and bone
structure can be created in terms of the
actual performance Lapita is scanned
using the medusa capture system from
disney research zurich this captures not
just her fixed facts facial expressions
but it's also used for animated lines of
dialogue this creates a library of faces
before principal photography we
sometimes call this the expression space
on set the actress has tracking dots and
these are used to solve her expressions
into that ilm shape library or space
this provides what Lapita is doing but
we still have to get her performance
retargeting to the new Mars face model
eylem uses a proprietary facial capture
system called snap sober to capture her
performance and then convert it through
medusa to something they can hand on to
the highly skilled ILM character
animation team who of course refines the
final performance Islands R&D team has
been collaborating very closely with
Disney research on the development and
integration of medusa system for
production use disney researchers Uruk
is a world leader in face capture and
eye scanning as I myself know and I can
testify to the fact their system is one
of the most detailed and advanced
systems in
world many of the actors were scanned
and this was used not only for the lead
digital characters but also for digi
doubles and a few x-wing pilots fighting
off the evil first-order well don't
forget to subscribe for more behind the
scenes action I might see more for Wired